[Musique]
l'histoire du canada autrefois mon pays
et est couvert de forêts il y avait des
animaux ça beaucoup de poissons aussi il
y avait aussi des indiens chez nous
autrefois
aujourd'hui autrefois serge simon et moi
qu il a été chef de la communauté de
gagner cette année pendant 10 ans les
indiens se faisait souvent la gare louis
les européennes
dans les années 60 il a fréquenté
l'école primaire francophone d'oka où
l'histoire qu'on lui enseigne et insisté
sur la violence et les massacres qu
aurait commis ses ancêtres l'amendé
choix n'est pas toujours des balles
dans ces manuels d'histoire du canada
pour les écoliers des années 50 et 60
les autochtones sont présentés comme des
sous-humains païens et sans culture ça
commence avec les proches de nous des
clés comme justement des sauvages chez
nous à baisser comme non important
pour juste fijda main le le vol de leur
territoire essayez de les assimiler le
plus possible il s'agit d'une histoire
coloniale mais on veut la faire passer
pour une histoire nationale évidemment
ça se tait pour l'école élémentaire
catherine larochelle est professeur au
département d'histoire de l'université
de montréal ces recherches ont porté sur
les discours impérialiste et raciste
dans les écoles québécoises au cours des
deux derniers siècles mais aussi son
importance de créer des ennemis et des
héros les exploits de ces héros donc ces
héros qu'on crée évidemment tombe
nécessaires à cette narration nationale
et au développement d'un sentiment de
fierté pour la patrie face à ces indiens
tes gosses et déshumanisée se dressent
des héros dont les plus connus sont les
missionnaires brébeuf et l'allemand
ainsi que dollard-des-ormeaux de leur
désormais mon préféré
soulom qu'un va élever une statue de
lots
et le national
d'après notre histoire nous su qu'il y
avait un mot n'est que monsieur
desormeaux après avoir volé les fours eu
des trappeurs et you quoi c'était un
ferme et d'un alfort et puis lisez leurs
quoi se sont
et monsieur désormais apparemment été
tellement saoul qu'il n'y avait plus un
baril de poudre qui avaient l'intention
de lancer aux zurichois salue bondi sur
une branche est lui revenu dans le
visage
et c'est ça un autre bout martin c'est
frappant quel point on voit que dans la
narration de l'histoire nationale si on
enlève les figurants autochtone du sens
du récit qui sont ces indiens féroce ya
plus de récits et donc il n'y a plus
cette capacité pour la communauté
canadienne française de s'affirmer comme
nation à la faux canada mais même sur le
plan international c'est à cette
propagande que serge simon a été exposée
quand il était écolier on voit tout
simplement que
ni zurichois ceux des méchins
coach tu es
à volonté ce qui est entièrement faux
moi je comprend un petit peu mieux
pourquoi est-ce qu'on est comme on est
gentil promet nation et réjean cible
de ces histoires à partir des années
soixante dix le contenu des manuels
traitant des autochtones gagnant nuances
mais encore aujourd'hui il reste du
chemin à parcourir selon la professeure
et j'en suis venu à penser qu'il faut
vraiment arrêter d'initier les enfants
québécois à cette matière là en
commençant dans le passé serge simon
croit encore qu'il ya de l'espoir il
beaucoup de choses qu'il faut changer
et je fonce on sait capable de créer une
nouvelle société
quelque chose de vraiment spécial
[Musique]